[Music]
damage control they're still cleaning up
for my Captain America takedown this guy
grab carriers for no reason I'm pretty
sure that was this try to save us from
tyranny yeah that's what that way you
think wonder why they take it all
[Music]
we can film it the real washing mind met
but we built very impressive very large
chunks of the monument for filming Jorge
coddles our stunt coordinator and he's
excellent
he knew what tom was capable of he
designed the stunts in such a way that
we could really capture them not just
from a spectacle standpoint but also
capture the emotion today was our first
day of spider-man climbing we've got him
on our slightly pitched war movie magic
and we've them around be climbing tom
for the first time on the wall he's done
a lot of rehearsal on this so hopefully
he'll make Salling today okay Tom stays
you are there and we're gonna walk you
across we didn't have to like film it
sideways we didn't have to turn the
camera sideways and see how it looked
afterwards we could see it immediately
and I could see myself an angle myself
to make sure I get the best position
yeah
[Music]